I'm thrilled to be here
today with Kelly Hawaii,
the author of build your dream network.
Uh,
Kelly is a connector and has been on the
Forbes one to five women changing the
world in VC and entrepreneurship.
She's appeared on CNBC is power pitch,
keeps a column on Inc Com and
tweets frequently at JK Hawaii.
In addition to our portfolio
of angel investments.
She's an LP in two funds and an advisor
to the New Zealand trade and Enterprise
Commission on top of these
professional pursuits.
Kelly is a chief tech ambassador
for the Y WCA at the NYC.
Keep Girls Club.
Please join me in welcoming Kelly.
Cool.
We're really excited to have you here.
Let me said he'll be here with you. Great.
So, uh, the word networking sends a
lot of chills or on people with downs,
people's spines,
including my own.
And I might even dare to say there's
other people in the room that would prefer
to treat the word networking like an
elephant in the room and maybe maybe keep
it a enclosed corners.
But without networking,
your career would have never
gotten to where you are today.
And you talk about this a bit in the book,
but would you mind sharing with us how
this idea of networking and how it's
creatively developed brought you
from 2002 to where you are today?
Yeah, so my uh, my background
is I'm an attorney.
I practice law in Canada
in an Inn New York City,
made a career change,
decided wanted to make a career change
in 2002 and realize I didn't have the
network to do it even though I was looking
for a career within the same industry
and everything synced.
Ben has come about because of networks
and relationships and purposely building
strong connections. So is Abby
mentioned, you know the word networking,
put chills in their spine. It puts a
chill in my spine too fast in the book.
I am a reluctant networker.
Um,
I was also very reluctant
in public speaking,
so the universe does really have
a way of coming back at you.
When you think of networking is
working a room, y'all think about,
you can say the word networking.
You'd probably imagining cocktail party,
there's a name tag that
you have to pin somewhere.
It probably balancing some sort of
a drink, trying to talk to someone.
Someone introduces you,
you're pulling off, you know,
some satay off a little stick.
He goes the horrors, right?
Like how are you talking about the weather
or something? You're just like, ah,
that is not networking. To me,
that's a networking tactic.
But networking to me when you think of
it as an activity is every single human
interaction.
So when you think about your own lives,
for me networking was your
decision to be here today.
You're networking is your
email signature line.
It's the headshot you all have on,
you know,
fabulous name tags are on social media.
Um,
it is, um, I dunno,
maybe someone leave a voicemail
message for someone else today.
Did you hand out a business
card? Did you, I dunno.
Leaving on out of office responder that
says you weren't going to be around to
me every time we interact with
someone else that is networking and,
and those micro-actions in my mind or
what are more effective in moving our
careers.
And our ambitions and our
relationships forward than relying on,
you know,
balancing a cocktail plate and handing
out a business card and having something
you know,
smart to say at a cocktail party.
So if networking is an activity I
want you to think of was every human
interaction and how can
you do those better.
Networking is a mindset.
I want you to think about it as this
is really hard for a lot of people.
How can you be a decent human being?
Because I think that's all we're ever
looking for is how can we have someone who
listens to us and is considerate
and the networking as well.
Where do you start when someone
says something foolish to you,
like do more networking cause he's
offered that one. That's great.
How do I start doing that
is where are you headed?
Where are you going?
What are you trying to achieve right
now with the help of other people?
And then who are the people who can
help you or the people already in your
network.
Are they groups or organizations that
you maybe think you need to join now?
How can you communicate with them better?
Because part of networking
is our preference on how
we communicate and engage
and the other is the person you want
to interact with. So I mentioned that.
I said voicemail as as uh,
I think it's an active networking.
My voicemail message,
if anyone calls me,
says please don't leave me a voicemail
message. I don't listen to them.
The number of people who still leave
me a voicemail messages is comical.
And I can tell you what I do with
every single one of them. Delete.
I've stated my preference,
text me or email me or tweet me,
do not leave me a voicemail.
I don't listen to these.
And they are with the
Twitter handle again.
So this is a pretty significant rebrand
to the idea of networking and especially
what we hear in business
communities or in, uh,
an MBA session or anything like that.
Well,
I always say we get so
unamortized I to say,
I think we've become so unnevered with
technology and ways things can do things
faster. We don't have to pull out
a paper map anymore, you know,
thankfully who can get us our directions.
We can click and swipe and tab.
But we need to remember behind all of
this is human beings and we have messy,
complicated, you know, unusual lives.
And on any given day, you
know, we can, you know,
be in a good mood or bad mood or you know,
have some trigger that sets us off.
And your reaction to something might be
different than my reaction to something.
And so I think, you know, if nothing else
from this book and people put people,
put people back in the center
of your networking and think,
how can I be someone other
people want to network with?
How can I be the person
I want to network with?
And just add that little consideration
into your daily activities and will make
all the world of difference.
So digging in
a little bit, one of the themes that
Kelly talks about in her book is the give,
give, get theory. And while it might
seem a little bit self explanatory,
it would love to hear your
thoughts on how you came to it.
When we're thinking about putting people
back in networking people back and
relationship building.
Well let me see the, the, the gift. I mean
it's great to be talking about it here.
You know,
that Google and in the heart of Silicon
Valley that where there is often been
and has been built on this give,
give, get mentality and that,
but that is sort of one of
those old rules of networking.
I think there's an element of,
of resurrecting ms manners or Craig
Claiborne and wrapping them around our
networking activities. Again.
Uh, and the idea is this is,
you know,
have you been a good person in
the community within your awkward,
within your, with, within
which you are operating.
Have you been that colleague who
has been helpful to other people?
Kathryn Finney who is interview
the book is very case study driven.
Kathryn Finney,
one of the interviewees,
and she's has the big
accelerator out of uh,
Atlanta as she says, you know, if you,
if you can't call upon a network,
you probably have a low
return on generosity and
then you need to look at what
your own interactions are. I
think that idea of the give, give,
get though is hard for some people because
there's often a networking imbalance.
You know,
you're looking to network with someone
who was higher up a corporate ladder or
someone who apparently has more resources,
connections,
then you do.
And that's where I come back to what I
said before about being a decent human
being.
Um,
are you considerate of somebody else's
time when you're asking them for advice?
Do you follow up and let them know
what you did with that advice?
Have you done enough research so that
if you're taking someone's time to ask
them the question, you're asking them
right question the right question.
If they've already written it on a blog,
if they shared it on a youtube video,
if they have posted an endlessly,
why would you ask a question that you
could find the answer to when a Google
search, you could do
that work, read it all,
take it all in and then
ask them a better question.
In my mind that is networking,
generosity and that is an essential give.
I think in this day and age
before you ask for you know,
time,
you know we have two resources in life,
really time and reputation.
One,
you can maybe earn back your reputation,
you can never get back your own time and
you can never give back anybody else's
time.
So really that,
that essential given networking for me
is like doing your homework before you
make that, that asks to maximize
that time and maximize the, the,
the giving of the other
person instead of wisdom and,
and realize that that level of
consideration is enough of a,
of a, of a gift. Because like
I said, people like, oh my God,
if I ask someone for you
know, an introduction, what
am I going to give them?
You don't need to give
them an equal introduction.
You may never have that opportunity
and they may never want it.
But you can give them consideration.
You can give them that kindness,
you can give them that
thoughtfulness and that,
I mean it sounds like a
really low base level,
but the number of people who,
who sort of like this is all we need.
Uh, one of the other people interviewed
in the book is Alison Levine.
Ellison is,
and how many friends do you get
to see in life or an adventurer?
And she's a best selling author,
but she's also an adventure.
She has led the first all us women's
team up Everest amongst other
accomplishments in mountains,
literally that she has climbed.
And when I asked her about, you know,
networking, generosity, what was the give,
because of course she's
accomplished so much.
People ask her for so much and she just
said, you know what, just be considerate.
Be considerate about the
time that you're asking for.
Get be considered about
what you're asking for.
Don't ask me if I've climbed Everest,
you know, Google search will reveal that.
And she was so adamant on this,
I had to call her and say, Allie,
I need to edit your answers for my book
because if I kept her original answers,
the book would come in a brown paper
wrapper with a parental warning.
A lot of all caps,
lot of imaginative words.
Uh, it's, it, it sounds crazy, but
like just that little consideration,
it makes all the difference.
So Alison was actually at Google
last week and now you're making me,
I'm going to watch her talk when
it was recording. She sounds,
it sounds fantastic.
Like seriously, if you missed
her person, watch her talk.
Alison Levine is extraordinary.
Okay,
fantastic.
So on that idea of frequent networking
asks that we might get or questions that
might come in often,
especially for someone like you
who identifies as a connector, uh,
one of the ideas I wanted to run through
by Kelly was to self assess and look at
some of the networking emails I've sent
or I've received with leading questions.
And I want to read these out cause I
think these are often networking crutches
that we land on.
I want to pick your brain about something.
Talk to the hand on that one.
Don't send that email and we'll break
it down and break some of these down
afterwards. But if you think
of anyone for this, nope.
Nope. Oh, do you have any
opportunities in mind for me to grow?
You mean you don't know everything
about my personal and professional
development?
Uh,
do you know anyone that might
want to cover this story
or give me some publicity?
The number of that last one,
the number of times I get that from,
from emerging tech companies who hired
PR firms and that's what they email me.
Oh,
for the love of God.
So as someone who's relatively young in
their career and when I'm thinking about
networking horizontal or
networking vertically,
and I'm talking to folks that I know I
want to make the most value their time,
but I also don't want to overstep. I don't
want to come off as a asking too much.
So sometimes it can feel more comfortable
to go back to these general statements.
Questions are asking too much.
Think about an email you get from a
friend that says, I'm looking for a job.
How does that feel when you get that?
You're like, I don't know where to start.
Yeah,
so what do you have to start by doing?
You have to start by asking a lot of
questions and we're racking your brain.
Well,
did you want a job at Google or where
you were looking for a job at Walmart?
I don't know.
Like what are you looking for?
And when you ask big general questions,
you're making your network do the work
for you rather than giving them that
target. Think about like darks. You gotta,
you know like you've got a
target that you're going for.
Tell them what your bullseye eye is
because then we have a radius of ways to
help you. So if you said, hey, I'm
looking for a job at x and you're like,
I don't know anyone at x, but I know
someone at why I don't know anyone at NBC,
but I know someone at ABC,
would you want to talk to them?
We have something to aim at. But if you
said, I'm just looking for a new job,
I don't know what to shoot for and now
you put the work on me and that is too
heavy of an ask.
I think our networks have
been extraordinarily strained
when I think of it from
a,
probably about 2009.
When you think the economic collapse
and uh, you know, Lehman brothers,
all of that stuff going on in people's
strained and looking for opportunities.
I think our networks are strained
because our nature of work has changed.
So many of us do freelance
or we're looking to get
opportunities and experiences
with, with within one company
and then we're moving to another.
So we're constantly moving in and
out of opportunities and networks.
So you're better off and you're,
you're helping your network,
you're helping yourself and you're
helping you get a better answer if you're
specific and people are afraid
of going specific and, and, and,
and maybe they're afraid
of doing the work,
but there are a lot of people say to me,
but if I do all that research and ask
the question, I have to do a lot of work.
And I'm like, yeah, that's a
point. That's why it's network.
So that work word in it,
but it's also, you know,
if you get off on just sending 50 emails
saying, Hey, I'm looking for a job,
can you help me this time sitting
around waiting for an answer as time,
why not do the research?
Find a smaller group of people within
your network who can provide you with the
right answer or closer
to the right answer.
Spend your spend your networking
time on that front end doing that.
Ask a better question. You don't
need 50 people emailing you back.
You need one or two and email you back
with the right opportunity. I think so,
yes to all of that. And to give a plug
here, buck and build your dream network.
You, one of the things that I loved about
this focus that you talked about how to
figure out what you're asking
in the networking anyways,
you should have a goal in mind.
And sometimes we know that this,
this ambiguous networking
concept is important,
but we don't know why we
need to be doing it. So,
and that brings to random
acts and networking. But when,
when you think of what you started,
like the bad name on networking. Like I,
if I don't know why I'm
in a networking room,
I mean I'm equally sweaty palms and
anxious as anyone else. I'm like, wait,
why am I here? What am I going to talk
about? But if I know why I'm there,
if I've made a conscious
decision to be there,
it's a heck of a lot easier to
kind of figure out. All right,
what are we going to talk about?
Um, what's, what's an introduction?
We question that I would want to say
to someone or if my networking is,
I just need to discover what this group
or organization or association is all
about.
I'm happy to go and sit quietly and
assess the landscape to understand, right?
Do I want to spend more
time here in the future?
But that all should aligned back to
the goals that you have set before even
walking into the room. Otherwise
you run around like with chicken,
with your head cut off and
listen, our time is, look,
we have not been able to hack time,
still only 24 hours looking on that.
Know, maybe someone's working on
it here, you know, uh, you know,
we can just reverse this
every once in a while. Um, um,
met George Takei at a south by a
few years ago and I said to her,
I'm still mad with star trek.
We don't have that, you know,
beam me up Scotty technology,
that would be good too.
But so we don't have more time in the day.
And for many of us,
you know what work is important.
There's other things that are important
and your network is also important for
your community service.
It may be important for other things in
your life and frankly just having time
to be with you know,
other people that are close to
you like make a priority for that.
So you know, I'm very much
about efficiency, you know,
maybe it's women multitasking,
how can you pack more into things we're
already doing rather to add more things
on when our time is
limited. Great. Thank you.
I would say for folks that are
interested more in about goal setting and
thinking about those,
those metal levels of career development,
I would highly recommend
checking out the book.
The chapters on goal setting helped me a
lot personally with thinking about time
at Google and it made some
of those networking questions
a little bit clear and
some of the steps easier to just apply.
One of the early readers of my
books called me up and said,
I've got some bad news about your
book. And I said, what's the bad news?
And she's like, it's not about
networking. And I'm like, yeah, I had,
I had that suspicion, I
had that suspicion. Uh,
and I think it is a bigger look at what
is it that you want to achieve and you
achieve things with the
help of other people.
Now how can you form better relationships
and how can you focus what you're
doing so you can achieve it.
So the case studies in the book range
from working up the corporate ladder to
crowdfunding to getting on
a national board to, uh,
I wouldn't say landing a job
right out of college. Um,
how Tina Roth Eisenberg
created creative mornings.
I've global network for the
creative community. So it's, it's,
it's more than just how you balance the
and work room and it has gotten a few
people thinking about Ra, where, what
do I want to achieve with my career?
Um,
what do I want to do after I retire?
I have a friend's mom inspired to start
her own business after she retires is a
school teacher in June
because she read the book.
That's pretty cool.
It's gonna be exciting to see where this
book brings people over the years as
well. Sure you're gonna be getting
some fun emails or tweets and those,
and those are the things
that mattered to me.
Like when I get those to think that, you
know, something is unlocked, you know,
something for someone else and now they
can pursue a path to their own success.
So in very gratifying in that.
So I want to jump back to something you
were talking about earlier around our us
owning our relations are a part of the,
our reputation and owning our time.
And one thing that really stood out to
me in the book was you kept bringing back
this idea of who knows what you know,
or the way I would rephrase
it as what are you known for?
And I think my question for you right
off the bat would be how do you know who
knows what, you know, I mean,
cause I put part of their, I see that
is, is I think about how we've evolved,
how the job market,
um,
and opportunities have evolved from who
you know and all those insider networks,
you know, to maybe what, you know,
cause it was a world driven by help.
Wanted and recruiters and classify ads
to now a world that where I put it is,
it's not who you know or what you
know, but who knows what you know. Um,
and I mentioned this in the book.
I remember when I was researching and
I pulled up something and it popped up.
I know it was in Linkedin.
It popped up an opportunity at Google.
So I went and clicked on it
and then it said, by the way,
who do you know at Google one at you
contact them? And I'm like, yeah,
what is the information you're sharing
with your network in terms of what your
interests are? Uh, you know,
what maybe you want to do next?
What in your life and your
career that you want more of?
Because the signals you send out,
maybe you know,
the stuff that starts coming to you as
the opportunities that you're really
seeking. So if you look at it,
go and look at your own profiles.
Go and look at the information that
you're sharing, whether it's in person,
online, or offline, uh,
with your community.
Because you may be sending out the wrong
signals in terms of what you want to be
found for.
I know like my profile and you don't
see anything about being a lawyer.
It is so buried and so minimal with
search words and everything else.
Cause Lord knows I don't
want to be contacted on that.
So when we're thinking about our email
signatures or our Twitter headlines or
even our bios on our
internal job search boards,
do you think that those should all
be the same and we should have it,
we should know what people
are identifying us. Make,
make sure it's powerfully moving forward.
Your ambition,
if you're posting things online,
you know,
what are the stories that you're sharing,
if, if, you know, are you sharing,
if you're sharing rich content that is
dealing with your professional and your
career interests in,
or are you sharing in a way that people
are identifying with something that you
either are an expert in or you want to
move into or something that you care
about? Uh, we have that ability in
mobility to move between things. I mean,
my own personal story was, um, in 2011,
2012, I co founded a startup
accelerator. It was not my idea though.
I was one of the cofounders,
the original idea came from my two
cofounders and they realized in launching
this nutty, crazy idea that they
needed somebody else to help them.
And they kept talking to people and
describing the skillset and the abilities
that they were in the background.
They were looking in this third cofounder,
nameless, third cofounder
and my name kept coming up.
Everyone kept saying, you know what?
He'd started to Kelly, you know,
you should talk to, you should
talk to Kelly. So what do
you want to be known for?
A network that, that experience
network, that ambition,
network, that skillset, but people
know what you're interested in.
Cause they may be like, oh, I
know who you're looking for.
You're looking for someone like Kelly,
are you looking for someone like Abby,
let me re you should talk to them.
Sounds like a great opportunity.
And that's how everything in my life
has happened really since 2009 for folks
that are listening in right now
and saying, that sounds great,
I need to update my
headline or my goodness,
I don't know what people know me for
right now. Do you have any take actions?
And I want to say a quick win.
They areas that people can take away
today to start to change their headline
changed, but they're known for.
Right? Well, I mean the take,
take an audit of every place where you're
interacting with other people and say,
you know, is this, is
there's this consistency.
Is this networking me forward
in the way I want to be found?
And then stop and think and
say, all right, how is my
network interacting with me?
What are they asking me for? How
are they engaging with me? Now?
How much of that is my network?
Like,
do I have the right mix of people in it
in terms of relationships and diversity,
uh, and, or how is my terms of
engagement with it that, you know,
I've enabled them to keep calling, calling
me back and asking for these things.
It's a little, you know,
so it's a little of both.
So go and go and do that audit
and sort of assess and say, oops,
what needs to shift and change?
Great action item for me.
I do it myself. I mean, I would say it is
one of those things, it's kind of funny.
Write a book on networking and you know,
they have to eat your own dog food and
I have to follow the advice between the
two covers. So I'm not just sitting up
here flippantly tossing, tossing out, oh,
you should do this. He's
like, I have to do it myself.
And I do catch myself the so,
wow.
So you actually just started
to touch on something that I'm,
I'm excited you brought up around
diversity of networks and um,
these where we find these groupings
and we actually had a great speaker at
Google last year,
a terror Winston.
I'm not sure if other folks
are able to tune in a,
she's from interacting consulting.
It was giving a skills building session
at Google last year and she had a quote
that stood out to me, uh, that
I'd love to hear your thoughts on.
She said she warned us against putting
your entire network in the same food
chain and I'll leave it at that.
I'd love to hear what you think about that
physician.
I was in,
in 2002 I had a network that was very
narrow and very deep within the legal
industry, but very particular within
the legal industry. It was, you know,
New York City in Toronto. It was
bankers, investment bankers, Wall Street.
Um,
I'm going to say trustees.
It was within a very
narrow area of practice.
And even though then my next career
move I saw within the legal industry,
you know,
I had nowhere to go unless I wanted to
go a general counsel and move to another
firm and do the same thing.
And so that was a big wake up call for me.
So I'm doing this because there's
basically two types of networks.
Some of them are associated with gender
and some of it I want to say like I
described my own legal career.
Some of us,
because of our industry in our profession,
we do this with our network.
It becomes very expertise in very narrow.
So there's an,
there's a narrow deep network
that's often associated with women,
the types of networks they have.
As I described it,
I had to guess I had the
double whammy on that.
I also had it cause I was a lawyer
doing a particular area of law.
The power and that network
is, that's where you have
people who've got your back.
Um, they're the people who you
know, can give you that feedback.
Maybe some deep mentorship. They
really know you well. That team,
you can instantly pull together.
On a project.
When you have a narrow deep network,
you can already see the problem with it.
It doesn't create a lot of opportunities.
So the other network is a broad,
shallow network that's
typically associated with the
types of relationships that
men have.
The reality is you need both.
You need those ties, those loose
ties or where opportunity comes from.
You may not be able to get deep feedback,
but you can sure spread
a message in a long way.
You share can find someone
to go, Oh God, yeah, right.
I went to college with
someone who's doing that.
Let me reach out to them and see
if they're interested in, you know,
talking about it or meeting or whatever.
You need both of those.
And the reality is our lives do that.
You know,
you thinking about when you are in college
and then those relationships ab out
this way further and further,
but find ways to keep those people
in your periphery. I mean our,
we're a case study of
that quote in many ways.
If you had had just said,
all right,
I had my nice internship for two
months in New York City in 2012.
Thanks very much. See you later. Yeah,
when I today here today,
right.
So Abby had been my intern and I think
that's also when you think about food
chain, we often think of
networking is up the food chain.
And the reality is we
live in a three 60 world.
You never know where opportunities are
going to come from. Your next boss may be,
you know,
30 years old or 30 years younger
was sort of nurture and take care
of all the relationships around you.
Back to being that decent human being.
Cause you never know.
You never know who's going to mentor you.
You never know where who's was an
opportunity's going to come from.
You never know who you can help.
And that just kind of creates that,
that vibrancy and resiliency in a network,
which in my mind creates the vibrancy
and resiliency in your own career. Great.
Thank you.
Um, I have a lot of more questions,
quite a few more questions. Um,
around social media.
You've talked a lot about generosity
and how that plays in the network and,
but right now I want to ask you one
more question then I want to open up to
folks on live stream and in
the room for questions. So uh,
start thinking about him or put them in
the door if you feel more comfortable.
But my last question for
you for now would be, um,
if anyone's here was to go home and
change only one thing about their know how
they network,
what would it be?
Change. One thing, it's like
the hunger games of your book.
You don't know what to do.
I said it to two different than these
are the biggest networking gives him
office to as what is the
biggest networking mistake
people make and the biggest
networking mistake people make
is a failure to follow up.
And I don't mean by that, the hey Abby,
you know the email I could send that say,
hey Abby, thanks for very much
for arranging this chat today.
It's when could I follow
up a month from now when?
Is there some time that you crossed
my mind that I could follow up again?
And that failure to follow
up with a piece of advice,
maybe an introduction someone
made, um, whatever it may be.
And if you do nothing else from today,
like go back to your desk and you know,
whatever,
sit there and look at your
calendar and think, right,
where is someone who has done something
for me that other than the hey,
thanks a lot.
Where can I circle back and let them
know what I've done with that guidance or
how something turned out and that that
type of follow up changes things within
networks and that changes relationships.
So if you do one thing from
today and change one thing,
like mastered the art of the followup,
that's a great note to take some
questions on. Thank you so much. Um,
I want to first open it up to the room
and see if we have any last questions.
I have a question on the gender issue.
So yeah,
Hindi aren't met and we met very
different in networking styles.
And how does that
differentiate the two genders,
South Korea development?
That is a terrific question.
In terms of networking
and career development.
Here's the two things that are
running through my mind. Um,
one is for people earlier in their
career, I often recommend them. I said,
look at what it takes for other people
to be successful in the area you want to
go into. And part of how they're
successful is not just the knowledge base,
it's how they interact and ask yourself,
will I be in successful
within that interaction.
So I knew I could be
successful as a legal career,
but if I'd chosen to be a tax attorney
I would have been an abject failure.
Their way of networking is very technical.
It is very research driven and it's very
paper driven in terms of writing papers
and things and giving, sending
updates. That is not me.
I was much better off hanging out as I
used to refer to them with my frat boy,
Wall Street clients.
Cause you know,
giving someone a Tequila shot was a heck
of a lot easier than spending endless
hours researching.
But that was my personality type.
So look ahead and say
how do they interact.
I also think this is where there is
power in knowing why you want to seek the
advice of other people.
Because we all operate within,
I would say proximity in communities
that they may have their patterns of
interactions and how you can,
you may not want to completely disrupted,
but you want to be part
of the conversation.
And this is where you have to find those
opportunities to seek out people in my
mind on their advice and their guidance
of how they can help you. So for example,
to reach out to someone and say,
please explain to me, you know,
why this happened in your career.
Like how did you make the
move from HR to engineering?
That intrigues me and it
doesn't seem to be, you know,
a linear career process.
How did that come about?
People want to talk and share
that of particular advice.
And so when do you find yourself within
an environment that you don't think,
well I'm not going to go out
and do that type of networking?
Yeah.
Find other ways to have conversation
that focuses back on the nature of work.
Does that help build a Doherty question?
So what advice do you have for introverts?
Oh, this is my favorite question.
Advice for introverts can,
we didn't talk about this.
I did mention that the buck is case
study driven and I saw people within my
network that had a particular
outcome and I said,
I need you to unpack this because I have
a suspicion that you have achieved this
school in a networked way
by building relationships,
seeking the help of others,
building your own expertise,
sharing that within your network and
moving towards whatever your goal is,
whether it's up the corporate
ladder, starting a, um,
I would say a venture capital
fund, climbing Everest, et cetera.
So I sent out questions to these people
in my book and I did not ask them one
question. I didn't ask them
their personality type. I
didn't ask, how'd you turn?
How'd you do on the Myers Briggs?
You know, how'd you do? No,
didn't ask that question.
And my answer's started coming back.
Most of the people are,
we're featured in the book are introverts
and not a little bit introverted,
really introverted.
I think in this day and age when we
are bombarded with opportunities and
information online and off and choice,
I think people who are more purposeful
and conscientious and how they network
are better networkers.
And my guess is those are introverts
in managing your own discomfort,
in managing your concern on what you're
asking may be and how it may feel or
impose on someone else,
I think you're better positioned
to succeed then extroverts.
I'm going to go really out on
a limb and say that one. Uh,
so my advice to introverts is anytime
someone sends you a networking tip that
says, you know, maybe it's a
link to an article that's hey,
10 things introverts can do to it, you
know, network more like extroverts.
I want you to hit delete immediately.
Someone sends you that advice.
I want you to ignore it.
Continue to be conscientious to compete
in you, to be purposeful, you know,
continue to understand why it is you
need to undertake networking activities.
One of the great case studies in the book,
he's a guy by the name of Joe Styler.
Joe Is at Godaddy.
He networked his way up from the help
desk to the aftermarkets department.
So cause I like to say,
you know,
in my way from being in New York
and on Wall Street, you know,
from being the receptionist at
Goldman Sachs to lead trader,
he's made that change in his career,
networking,
building his expertise, moving his
career forward within his industry, um,
very purposefully and very intentionally
with it and go daddy. And he's like,
hey, there's things I know I have
to do that, you know, I'm not,
if I look at my personality type,
I know I'm not comfortable doing them,
but I understand now why I need to
do them so I can step into that room.
And he's so purposeful and
so well researched anytime.
I think it's to manage that discomfort.
But his case study is an absolutely
brilliant one in terms of someone who is
introverted,
moving their career forward.
Because if he had succumb to into
introversion and just been told, you know,
go network, go work cocktail parties,
you'd probably still be, you know, hey,
thanks for calling, go daddy, this is Joe.
How can I help you instead of in a very
fulfilling role within that company and
within the industry. A tactical
question on Linkedin, uh,
what is your thoughts on the linkedin
open networkers and how can you use them
as a resource? Uh, struggling with
that. They open networkers attempts,
people actively connecting
with other people on Linkedin,
right? So they, you know,
if you send them a connection,
you don't have any connection with them,
they will automatically approve you
in their network. I want to know why.
So one of the things they,
the benefits they do,
which may not be a
benefit for individuals,
but they are able to connect groups that
are not actually connected together.
So there's a good society
that these people play.
But I didn't know how other as
a individually, tactically, uh,
for those folks. Yeah. I mean,
here's the thing. I mean I
as a networking platform and
to date myself as a Rolodex,
as a way of keeping eyeballs on contacts
and thinking about who and when to
contact people depending on where I'm
going or industries I'm looking into.
I'm a massive fan of linkedin. Um, and
I think also too, it is revealed to us,
you know,
it's not only your own network,
it is the second and third
degree connections and sort
of unveiling that concept
to people hadn't heard of it.
I think it's vitally important
that like Linkedin as a platform.
But there's two things with linkedin.
I think we look at it as a platform and
technology and we forget that people use
it differently and we use it
differently at different points in time.
So I request to connect without a,
without a personal message,
I think is meaningless.
Tell me, remind me,
prompt me how and why.
And then when you do
that with other people,
also remember some of us may be
using the network differently.
I know some people who use
linkedin very closed off.
If we haven't sat, you know, face
to face. If we haven't broken bread,
you're not in my linkedin network.
Other people are, oh, you know what?
I'm expanding my business. I've got
a new role in sales. I've, you know,
my own case, I'm going to book
this out. It's a lot wider.
So if someone was to message
me on linkedin and said, hey,
loved hearing your talk at
the University of Tampa,
like I was the one who asked this
question, I'm likely to connect with them.
It also makes it, when someone
says, can you make an introduction?
I see you're connected on Linkedin to this
person, can you make the introduction?
That's also where you need to understand
that they may not have the strongest
connection to people to make
an introduction. So I would
be able to say, oh yeah,
that person, I know them. We
connect it in Tampa for 10 minutes.
You can reach out and use my name,
but I don't think I can be that meaningful
in terms of anything in depth, in a,
in a connection. But we use it
differently. And I think there's, that's,
you've hit on something in my mind
which is bigger, is that we don't,
when you have digital
tools around networks,
when we focus on the tools
themselves and the technology,
we forget that people
use them differently.
And we're just remember always
as human beings behind that. And,
and think about ways,
the way that you using something is not
necessarily the way somebody else uses
it. And, and, and I would
say for anyone, you know,
you're in the room and anyone
watching, so on my website, Jay Kelly,
hawaii.co, it's a.co, not a.com.
There's a little box that says,
ask Kelly crazy thing comes to me,
comes into my Gmail account. Uh, there
is no one in between that. So if I,
if you don't get your question answered
today, just fire me the question.
Say that you were watching this and
you've got a question and I'll answer up.
Jay Kelly,
hawaii.co ask Kelly and Kelly answers.
Great. Thank you. I to build on
top of the previous question,
what other tools do you use
to keep track of fuel network?
Oftentimes I realized that I don't
remember if people verbal and in order for
juniors, I think of this
problem of short memory and uh,
oftentimes I would find myself,
he there was this problem and I didn't
think of conducting this person and only
two weeks later to realize he would
have solved this issue very quickly. Eh,
I wish I had like the magic solution for,
for remembering these
things. I am very, um,
I want to say geography based in my
thinking in terms of when I start problem
solving. If I think of networking as it
gets the way you've just described it,
like problem solving, who can
help me with this problem? Uh,
I'm often very geography or um,
company based.
When I think of it sometimes I'm
like, okay, where did I meet them?
Where did I meet them? And I have to
kind of like go down this waterfall.
I would say for anyone,
like figure out how you start to
problem solve in these situations.
Like who,
who have I met and then you'll probably
figure out what is the best way for you
to organize your contacts.
Are you someone who would go to Linkedin?
Is a spreadsheet the answer for you,
is there some other,
yeah.
Is it groups on,
you know on on a Google
plus like figure it out.
Start to think about how you
problem solve and need the help of other
people and figure out van from there.
Right. Where the ways I can clump people
in different things to be able to say,
you know what, I just met this person
we talked to about this stuff. He might,
he or she may be a good person to ask
this type of question in the future.
Figure a way to tag them or do something.
But that part of,
I think maybe all of this with
the book and networking is,
is whole lot of self awareness,
a whole lot of self awareness about
how you operate within this world,
but how you reach out to other people
and how you can do that in a way that is
more effective. But I mean, I
wish I had the ultimate dashboard.
Maybe that's the next thing I
create. 2018. Yeah, there we go.
Then we in August didn't have
enough projects to be all come on,
come up with a dashboard because it is,
it is something people are
always like where, where is
the, you know, the Rolodex,
the CRM system.
Okay.
You know, I am not a spreadsheet person,
but if that's what works for you,
put it in a spreadsheet.
Okay.
And so great to have you here and um,
I hesitate to say if you want to leave
us with any parting wisdom because I
think that's what the last
45 minutes was all about.
Any closing thoughts or final,
final remarks before we wrap?
I just want to say go forth and, you
know, be better human beings. So it's,
that's all that we all can
ask for. And I think, uh,
we understand that we're networking
with other people that their lives are
complicated and messy.
If we can stop and observe and listen
a little bit more in our before we
interact, we will improve
our interactions. Thank
you. That's great. Kelly.
It's been tight.